« La sociologie, c’est moi. », dit
Bourdieu dans les années 1970.
Il dit à un journaliste vingt ans plus
tard : « Maintenant, en France, il n’y a
plus d’intellectuels à ma hauteur, je suis tout
seul dans ma catégorie, les autres sont morts.
Les seuls avec lesquels j’ai envie de rivaliser
maintenant, ce sont les grands patrons ».
Mais un jour, un auditeur l’interpelle
lors d’une conférence : « Bourdieu
n’est pas Dieu ! ».
Nous avons peu de recul, car
Bourdieu est décédé il y a seulement 20 ans.
Mais nous pouvons le voir comme le dernier maître
à penser de la gauche française, le
dernier grand penseur français
— et peut-même le dernier grand penseur
tout court sur le thème de l’inégalité,
dans la lignée de Rousseau et de Marx.
Bourdieu a également joué un rôle majeur dans
la mise en avant de la sociologie, longtemps
restée dans l'ombre de la philosophie.
Après, ses idées ne sont pas forcément
nouvelles, et son style est complexe.
Mais Bourdieu a eu, et a toujours une
ÉNORME influence intellectuelle.
Il a changé la vision du monde
de beaucoup de gens.
Comment est-ce qu’il a réussi
ce tour de force ?
Je vais vous raconter 10 anecdotes
particulièrement révélatrices.
Vous allez voir que Bourdieu
est un homme exceptionnel.
Après, certaines de mes
anecdotes sont dérangeantes.
Bourdieu, le défenseur des
faibles, n’est pas un saint.
Nous sommes en 1948.
Pierre Bourdieu entre en prépa littéraire au
prestigieux lycée Louis-le-Grand, à Paris.
Une des choses les plus pénibles pour lui,
c’est de corriger son accent.
Eh oui, il vient d’un village du Béarn, une
région historique du sud-ouest de la France.
Chez lui, on ne parle pas le français,
mais la langue locale, le béarnais.
Donc Bourdieu n’est pas du tout un rejeton
des élites parisiennes.
Ni même un bourgeois.
Il est un bon exemple d’ascension
sociale par l’école.
Son père est un postier qui a,
lui, arrêté l’école à 14 ans.
Sa mère, femme au foyer, a
arrêté l’école à 16 ans.
Après, la famille de Bourdieu n’est pas aussi
modeste qu’il le laisse parfois entendre.
À l’époque, postier — le métier du père
— n’est certes pas la position la plus
prestigieuse — mais un postier gagne aussi
bien, sinon mieux sa vie qu’un instituteur.
Le père de Bourdieu jouit également
d’un logement de fonction.
Quant à sa mère, elle vient
d’une bonne famille.
Elle a hérité de la maison, de telle sorte que
les Bourdieu sont propriétaires par héritage.
Bref, on est loin de la misère.
Mais c’est vrai qu’en termes de capital culturel,
Bourdieu n’a pas tiré les bonnes cartes.
S’ils ne sont pas bac+10, ses parents ne
l’empêchent pas pour autant de faire des études.
Ils l’inscrivent en internat au lycée.
Ses résultats y attirent l’attention du
proviseur, lui-même béarnais et ancien normalien,
ainsi que l’attention du recteur d’académie.
Ils envoient leur pépite en prépa littéraire
à Louis-le-Grand, la meilleure de Paris.
Bourdieu réussit du premier coup le concours de
la prestigieuse École Normale supérieure.
Il y entre en 1951.
À cette époque, il y a deux stars
pour les élèves de l’école.
Sur le plan de la pensée, ils admirent
Maurice Merleau-Ponty, le philosophe de
référence sur le thème de la perception.
Mais sur le plan du rayonnement intellectuel,
la star, c’est bien sûr Sartre.
Les nouveaux normaliens vont rendre visite
au chef de file de l’existentialisme.
Bourdieu, lui, évite cette cérémonie.
« C’est pour les petits cons », dit-il.
« Je suis un produit de l’École normale
qui a trahi l’École normale »,
écrira-t-il dans Réponses.
Bourdieu est donc un renégat de
l’élite académique française.
D’un côté, son parcours fait de lui un pur produit
de l’excellence académique à la française.
Il a toujours été un bûcheur, et il a toujours
eu de très bons résultats scolaires.
Mais de l’autre côté, il a un regard
critique sur le système qui l’a produit.
Contrairement à d’autres normaliens —
Pompidou ou Raymond Aron, par exemple — il
ne voit pas l’École Normale supérieure
comme un sanctuaire de génies.
Au milieu de la vingtaine, Bourdieu
est prof de philo au lycée de Moulins,
une ville du centre de la France.
De retour à Paris, il loge chez les parents
d’un ami de l’École Normale supérieure.
Le père de cet ami a une énorme bibliothèque.
C’est une véritable mine d’or pour Bourdieu.
Il y passe la nuit, à dévorer les livres.
Une raison de la grande culture de
Bourdieu, c’est qu’il est insomniaque.
Si on ne dort pas, on a beaucoup
plus de temps pour lire !
Donc depuis l’adolescence, Bourdieu met
à profit les heures de la nuit pour lire
tout ce qui l’intéresse.
Et puis pour travailler.
Ça sera comme ça toute sa vie.
Lorsqu’il aura une équipe d’assistants,
il n’hésitera pas à les déranger la nuit.
Luc Boltanski — qui est le coauteur d’une
analyse de référence sur le capitalisme
néolibéral de la fin du XXe siècle,
Le nouvel esprit du capitalisme
— Luc Boltanski travaillait avec Bourdieu
dans les années 1960, et il lui reprochait
ses coups de téléphone nocturnes, qui ne
manquaient pas de le réveiller.
Moulins, la petite ville où Bourdieu enseigne,
offre peu de distractions.
Il y a quand même une librairie.
Bourdieu y achète le Manifeste du parti
communiste de Marx et Engels.
Et le libraire… le dénonce
au proviseur du lycée !
C’est que Bourdieu est un prof
original qui inquiète un peu.
Comme Sartre avant lui, il enseigne
avec sa propre méthode. Il veut ouvrir
l’esprit de ses élèves.
Il parle sans notes. Il donne
des exemples intéressants issus de la
poésie, de la peinture, de la musique,
ou de l’expérience quotidienne.
Il continue à parler avec les élèves en dehors
de la salle de classe, un sandwich à la main.
Il se charge même de l’éducation musicale de deux
fils de paysans prolétaires qui ne connaissent de
musique que l’accordéon des fêtes populaires.
Il les invite chez lui et leur fait
écouter de la musique classique.
Il intéresse également sa classe à l’actualité
en abonnant le lycée à un hebdomadaire.
Après, Bourdieu ne se contente pas de transmettre
du savoir — il se méfie même de l’érudition.
Il comprend que ce n’est pas en se bourrant
la tête de connaissances que les élèves feront
des progrès en dissertation, mais qu’ils
ont intérêt à améliorer leur style.
Donc il les encourage à écrire un paragraphe
par jour, et il leur corrige.
C’est pragmatique : pour écrire une bonne
dissertation, il faut s’entraîner… à écrire.
Bourdieu avait compris cela il y a 70 ans.
Mais la plupart des profs actuels
n’ont toujours pas compris.
Le fait que Bourdieu soit un bel homme au
sourire ravageur, ça lui facilite la tâche.
Il est charismatique, il attire l’attention.
Au lycée et plus tard à l’université, les
étudiants sont sensibles à son charme.
Nous sommes en 1997. Bourdieu a 67 ans.
Il écrit au Premier ministre Lionel Jospin.
Pour lui demander quoi ?
De protéger un homme qu’il a connu à Moulins : le
dentiste des pauvres Bernard Jeault.
Réveillé par Mai 68, ce dentiste décide
de fournir des soins dentaires de qualité
aux gens qui n’en ont pas les moyens
Il se met alors à dos l’Ordre des
chirurgiens dentistes et l’administration,
qui lui interdisent d’exercer.
Alors même qu’il est malade,
Bourdieu remue ciel et terre pour venir
en aide au dentiste des pauvres.
Cette anecdote illustre la sympathie
spontanée de Bourdieu pour les dominés.
Il est très sensible à leur aliénation,
pour parler comme un marxiste.
Et il ne s’agit pas simplement
de sentiments et de paroles.
Contrairement à beaucoup de partisans
d’une plus grande justice sociale,
Bourdieu agit concrètement : il intervient
pour améliorer le sort des dominés.
Il n’a pas non plus attendu
d’être célèbre pour le faire.
À l’ENS, par exemple, il prête une
machine à écrire à une femme de ménage
désireuse d’apprendre la dactylo.
Bien sûr, c’est pas la révolution — mais
c’est d’une générosité rare.
Ce n’est pas pour mettre en application une
théorie que Bourdieu aide les gens des classes
sociales inférieures — c’est parce qu’il en
ressent intérieurement le besoin.
Il se veut le défenseur des
faibles face aux forts.
Il est généreux avec les faibles,
et dur avec les forts.
C’est probablement de son père,
postier syndicaliste dans un village du Béarn,
que Bourdieu a hérité sa sensibilité sociale.